[Music]
hey guys Dimitri from the score eSports
so what do Dan Marino Charles Barkley
and Barry Bonds have to do with peanuts
Joe knack and a guardian well they're
all in an elite group of players who
despite their remarkable talent and many
accomplishments never managed to win the
big one now when we say the big one
we're not talking about regional
qualifiers domestic titles or any old
generic premier tournament we're talking
about worlds we're talking about Ti the
majors the be-all and end-all of
whichever game these competitors chose
to make their mark so let's get on with
our list picking off our list is one of
the most iconic players to ever grace
the NA LCS stage a player whose
trash-talking and mechanical skill have
cemented him as North America's greatest
ad carry of course we're talking about
the one and only double lift everyone
else's trash concert throws back Cooney
goes down now it's gonna be on a wild
turtle they try to get any platformers
that's gonna be the head wild turtles
getting the ricochets now they're
doublelift rather I should say and it's
the triple kill going forward in the
fight pen they catch bait that's gonna
hit the path to his nod do they turn
around for the kill
bots are fighting a minion almost
[Applause]
originally double lifts empty trophy
case was a meme throughout the league
community but in 2015 he finally got a
taste of regional glory and the faithful
shall be rewarded
take a trip to world this is going to be
it counter logic gaming fighting every
season since there has been one and now
taking down
yet despite winning the na LCS
seven times he has yet to make it out of
groups at Worlds I think I think it's
good to have high expectations of your
the teams that you want to see succeed
like it's not acceptable that I go to
Worlds every year as the first seed and
I [ __ ] the bed and I just I never
perform and my team never makes any
groups and yeah I mean Jesus I don't
think I was gonna get emotional actually
oh that's alright but like I like it's
been eight years and I can't do this
thing but I'm just I'm never gonna give
up so that's what I want to say from
league of legends to a Yoshi legend AMSA
comes in at number 9 on our list hailing
from Miyagi Japan AMSA was always
selective of the tournaments he competed
it but when he did make an appearance he
made sure to let the world know why he
earned the title of best Yoshi
[Applause]
[Applause]
throughout 2017 i'm Ciroc dub impressive
wins over some of the game's best
to talk jump at him
she'll don't you bet she'll chill but
despite all these upsets he has yet to
finish a tournament on top coming in at
number eight is not a player but rather
a team as it would be criminal to leave
the New York excelsior off this list
despite not making a name for themselves
in apex as LW blew the roster joined the
overwatch League as the New York
excelsior and took the league by storm -
are you kidding me this guy handedly an
incredibly flexible team that could
adapt to any meta due to possessing
superstar players like season one MVP
Joe knack who is also the only player to
have his own skin amassing an incredible
11 game win streak they fell short in
the second round of over watches
inaugural season grand finals despite
being unanimously favored to win the
whole thing
[Applause]
[Music]
town motto will it be kill their build
up the effusion they need to win this
fight New York needs it even more but
there goes Matt goes back
[Applause]
have they set themselves to the
overwatch League grand finals I think
they may have they have double marks the
only one left
[Applause]
for number seven we go to one of the
longest-tenured players in all of
eSports needed
killing spree it's shocking that in made
its illustrious 12-year career he was
unable to win a major 4v4 event from
halos golden years halo 2 to halo 3 he
was always one of the scenes most
decorated players after an impressive
second place showing an MLG Chicago in
2006 he teamed up with some of the
greatest halo players of all time but
was still unable to win it all I've been
to 60 plus in this me I've been
competing for 10 years one of the
biggest things is the be on a winning 40
14 at a major event I've come so close
so many times second third I think
that's one of the big things that keeps
meat mungry is not getting that title
our number six entry features a true
eSports tragedy and to be quite honest
the fact that a beloved ingenious dota 2
playmaker like FY has yet to win a TI
still baffles us to this day
[Applause]
that's the game
without a question one of the best if
not the best position for supports ever
to play the game
FY has excelled at every hero he's Villa
Hill they actually managed to get a
really good set FY he sleeps himself
four steps away trying to get some
distance death really but will not be
able to get away from 19 years old
FY established himself as the new and
upcoming support on vici gaming where he
played his first final at ti4 but lost
to newbie despite being the better team
on paper four years later FY would find
himself in another ti final against og
where they would lose a heartbreaking
series that went to the full five games
it's almost an anomaly in the dota 2 pro
scene to make it to two finals and it's
even more rare to lose both coming in at
number 5 maybe the least decorated
player on our list but he is without a
doubt one of the best top laners in
League of Legends history and if you
haven't guessed it already we're of
course talking about flame qss up the
chase these tam Caicos down the flame
brothers where did you go
very in fact all these teammates at
immortal they fought their way out of
the corner lubbers that fight got a
triple feel another nicknamed the pilot
due to his ability to hard carry his
team to victory flame in his early years
would put the team on his back and while
his reputation for reigning terror in
the top lane was known to League fans
his lack of success is another story
unlike most of the players on this list
flame has yet to even win a domestic
title as a starter in any of the three
major regions he's played in despite
being considered a product as well
das 40s dips intense splits they have
never missed a final they have never
missed world and they are once again
your North American champion we can only
hope that he could one day hoist a
trophy before his playing days are
extinguished just falling short of the
top three is CS goes deadliest player
simple nitro does have a most often
under smoke so it could be really rough
for several times to get through this
he's considered by many as the single
greatest counter-strike player of all
time
return jumps up and somehow points
Sergey but he hasn't found the palm he
will now and he goes away from default -
wait I don't want to get an A - the ELSA
knows there's a flank and he also knows
he needs it they actually get the first
one he's got a chance he knows how loose
up simple has yet to win a major think
faker without the World Championship
titles while he is the world's best csgo
player he has always hit the road block
of facing a team that is just better
than his a team in the middle of a
dynasty touching the pomp article to
peak holding it now and there is it
despite taking home seven tournament
MVPs he has yet to bring home a major
tournament victory taking the number
three spot is a team so lovable and fun
to watch that it breaks our hearts to
say that we will never see them win the
big one you're damn right we're talking
about the Rox Tigers specifically their
2016 roster when it comes to the 2016
iteration of the Rox Tigers you could
make an argument that four out of five
players were the best at their positions
in the world and after years of falling
short they managed to win the 2016 lck
summer finals and secured spot at the
World Championship and this baby in Rox
Tigers moving in it's a five feet four
they're gonna get the final inhibitor
and now this group of players that have
either retired or been rejected by other
teams
no big sponsor no big team house it's
that necessary because they are going to
lck summer and they are going to get a
spotted world to get there it is brunch
Tigers taken JJ it's about time in a
meta that heavily favored them it looks
like their time had finally it has been
killed and they even got the pickoff on
Bank rocks doesn't actually have to stop
pushing right now they can delay the
recalls
[Applause]
but a team by the name of SKT had other
plans
the Rox Tigers lost in five games in
what some considered one of the best Bo
5 Series and League of Legends Jason is
alive but no split right now for banging
it won't be up in time but they don't
they say happy endings only exist in
movies and in the case of the Rox Tigers
I guess that's true coming in as the
runner-up is Guardian one of the best if
not the best opera of all time it's
unfathomable that he is yet to win a
major Guardian he's trapped behind the
box he get stuck
he goes from boys gonna hit up tennis
and now it's sort of a County how I get
the job oh my god he picks up four kills
and wins it especially when you consider
that he's been playing CS professionally
since 1.6 Guardian has been constantly
featured in the hltv top 20 list since
2013 that was maybe the only choice but
Guardian comes back in oh god idiot -
this still wants to go go how they must
want the ball the peaks come in fact
Guardian will not stop one more to go
and Guardian yes them all even at his
best he just seems to be unable to
secure a major victory he's played in
three major finals and has lost all
you cannot miss a single shot Guardian
waits patiently as Kyle myself the
push-up finishing at the top of our list
is none other than art burning [ __ ] back
Andrea gauges 4:30 trying to finish him
up or come no I'm not tanky enough they
can't finish our tour unstoppable can he
finish the party z PK be activated but
he's chunking him down
our TZ entered the scene in 2013 and was
considered a prodigy at his first land
he destroyed legendary mid laners like
Dendy mushi and s4 he was then picked up
by evil geniuses and helped the NA squad
cement themselves as one of the world's
but after losing out of Ti for he left
AG to join his secrets forming one of
the greatest super teams in the history
of the game
but despite the star power around him RT
Z failed to win ti5 alongside our TZ
bounced back and forth between evil
geniuses and team secret over the course
of the next few years and every time the
results were well disappointing now back
once again with evil geniuses and the
true tragedy of our TZ is that despite
being hailed as one of the best carries
ever to play the game he is still yet to
play in a major or ti final let alone
win one well guys that's our list be
sure to LIKE the video subscribe to the
channel and let us know in the comments
when you think any of these incredible
players are bound to win the big one see
you next time thanks for watching if you
want more content like this hit the sub
button and ring that notification bell
for unique bite-sized videos you will
find anywhere else hit up our Instagram
Twitter and Facebook pages
you